welcome back to the bench pure osho i'm
michael knowles filling in you can find
me at the michael knowles show on apple
podcasts and wherever you get your
podcast you can find me on twitter and
michael j knowles and if you happen to
go over to twitter to find me
you may find a man named matt walsh who
I don't think has ever had a thought
that has not gone to Twitter and that's
actually a very good thing because I
think Matt has probably the best Twitter
commentary and other sort of commentary
on this moment on black lives matter on
the riots on the statue toppling he's
probably got the best commentary out
there on it I'm joined by the great host
of the Matt Walsh show Matt Walsh thanks
for coming out man
hey well thanks for that introduction
I'm sure I won't live up to it but yeah
that's guaranteed no man I got to tell
you I was I was scandalized by some of
your commentary you have said things
that is so offensive so outrageous so
politically incorrect also so true that
I don't even know that I can associate
with you anymore
well I understand that that's it but the
thing is it's so easy these days to you
know to say things that are provocative
because things that even like five years
ago would have been standard commentary
at least on the right are now are now
like whoa how could you say that
especially when it comes to you know
things like criticizing BLM radical
Marxist organization it suddenly were
squeamish about criticizing them I don't
even understand it yeah yeah and but
that's that's where we are that's where
we are it's funny you mentioned five
years ago because there was this clip
that came up I guess it was a little
longer as seven years ago just came
around of Don Lemon CNN's far-left Don
Lemon he played a clip of Bill O'Reilly
talking about how everyone's focusing on
this very small number of
officer-involved killings of black men
but not focusing on the massive crime
rates within black communities the real
social problems that are affecting
people there and Donna and play the clip
and he goes you know Bill O'Reilly has a
point and then and then Don Lemon
proceeds to go on a rant that that the
most far-right media channel today would
not be permitted to give and of course
Don Lemon himself or anyone else on CNN
would never give it today what shifted
seven years is not a long time
yeah well and we see this with with
every issue it seems like we're we've
got this cultural dissent that's
happening and it feels kind of gradual
but then there are these moments you
know it's similar it's kind of like with
the transgender issue too you know you
go back ten years ago and almost nobody
was was was seriously entertaining the
idea of having men in women's bathrooms
and then it seems like almost overnight
it's a mainstream point of view than
even people on the right are afraid to
to contradict it so it just it's like
we're going along and we're descending
down the slippery slope and then and
then something happens usually there's
some sort of event that precipitates it
and the slope turns into a cliff and
it's just a freefall and I think that's
what happened
it's what happened with this George
Floyd thing and and and with racial
issues where as you point out I mean
that there's stuff now that people on
the right are afraid to say that people
on the Left would have said a few years
ago and that's that's where we're at
right it it's kind of counterintuitive I
suppose to because I think a lot of
people thought in 2008 that electing the
first black president would be the
cherry on top of the sundae of solving
racial issues in America you know
obviously some bigotry is gonna lurk in
the heart of man because man is wicked
from the beginning right that's just
part of our human nature but it seems
like we pretty much solved like every
single racial issue in the country then
you'll like the first black president
she is show ok this country is not
racist even though Barack Obama was
completely unqualified to be President
we still elected him he was a frankly
more impressive candidate than his
Republican rival that year anyway in
terms of campaigning and so great now
all the racial problems are solved right
except it seems as though since that
time they've only gotten much much worse
yeah it hasn't and the interesting thing
is that the left they have you think
about all that all the celebrating that
went on over Barack Obama being elected
president we all remember that and I was
not an Obama fan at all to say the least
but it was it was significant that you
know you think you go back 150 years and
black people were slaves and then you go
back only a few decades and you had
segregation civil rights and now a black
man is being elected president so
there's supposed to be this this is this
great historic moment which at which it
was at least it was historic anyway but
now they
the left is basically gone back and said
that was meaningless it had no meaning
whatsoever and it does not reflect at
all that systemic racism has it's not
just that systemic racism still exists
it's that according to them it's as bad
as it's ever been it might even be worse
than it's ever been so they have so what
was the what was the advantage what was
the point of even electing a black man
president apparent according to them not
nothing at all this is what seems to
always happen with the left actually
specifically with Obama
we were told Barack Obama's gonna pass
universal health care Obama care this is
it this is gonna solve the health care
problem in America and it was this
zillion dollar plan that was very
disruptive through a lot of people off
of their health insurance a lot of
people had to lose their doctors prices
went up premiums went up I mean it was
it was so massive in its consequence
major Supreme Court case that was
decided because of it that upended a lot
of legal jury is Amman and jurisprudence
and then we're now told it doesn't
matter at all we it didn't affect the
health care debate we now we need
socialized medicine it's as if it's as
if none of that which we grant to the
left earns us any credit it's just the
the march of progress continues apace
yeah and that's and that's a lesson that
I wish people on the right would learn
that it doesn't as you say whatever you
grant to them it doesn't matter there's
no point of making any concessions
because it won't make a difference
anyway it's it's not going to inoculate
you from criticism at all but I think
what we find is that the you know the
left of course they they operated on a
victim narrative that's the way it's
been for decades which means that even
when they own the culture and they
achieve every victory they they they
achieve everything they set out to
achieve they still have to paint
themselves as the victim which means
ironically denying even their own
successes because if they acknowledge
their own successes then they have to
give up the victim narrative which they
can't do it because if they give up the
victim narrative then they're not gonna
have any more successes and so it's the
that's the way the cycle works I guess
that's a great way to put it because
I've been trying to think about this
there's been a big debate that's broken
out on the the problems with liberalism
itself you know Kath lowercase L
liberalism that you're always you're
always liberating yourself from
something kind of the premise of
liberalism
there's an oppressive past and you got a
you got to liberate yourself beyond that
but what happens when you run out of
oppression what happens when you run out
of villains well you've got to invent
villains and it that seems to me what's
happening now I mean early on in the the
riots we were told actually these are
totally peaceful protests and the only
violence that's being committed is being
committed by white supremacists I think
there are about what seven white
supremacists in the country I mean it
seems to be kind of an illusion and when
you looked at the riots certainly that
did not seem to be the case so is it
does it this just all basically boil
down to to fantasy I I think it does and
I think we have to be a lot bolder than
we're being in confronting this
oppression narrative because the fact is
yes there there there's there still
injustice that happened in this country
there's always gonna be injustice yeah
because we're never gonna be a utopia so
but but most of the oppression narrative
is just imaginary these are these are
people who are imagining fantasizing
about oppression that simply doesn't
exist and we know that we know that
based on if you look at the statistics I
mean things like this idea that the
racist cops out executing innocent black
men it's just that's just not happening
is every year there are there are maybe
one or two questionable police shootings
a handful at most but the vast majority
of police shootings are obviously
justified and of course we also know
that the real threat that black men in
the city face is is within their own
community from criminals and murderers
and things like that so you know we you
can look at that I mean you can look at
this dead people inventing hate crimes I
mean we go back through history and at
oppressed and persecuted groups you know
can we find examples of actual oppressed
and persecuted groups who invent more
oppression for themselves
it wouldn't be necessary to do in the
first place and they would have any
appetite for it so I think that in
itself proves something right you do see
this a lot you see a number of hoaxes
it's not even on racial issues but on
sexual issues I mean it just it seems to
crop up often I don't know it might be
the sign of a of a culture that once you
overcome all of the actual oppression
you don't know what to do you've kind of
you've kind of lost the narrative and I
see this even his
aurélie you've made this great point on
Twitter which is that the entire premise
of tearing down the statues of
Washington even and Jefferson and
Lincoln and st. Junipero Serra and now
they're tearing down everybody the
argument is that no matter how much good
they did they're tearing down actual
Saints but no matter how much good they
did if they ever did anything bad at all
or if they even look like people who did
anything bad at all we've got to tear
down their statues and yet at the same
time that we're tearing down statues of
George Washington we're putting up
murals actual monuments to George Floyd
whose death started off all all of these
riots how do you reconcile those two
things yeah and the point we have to
make is that these murals it's such as
murals or naming streets after him
buildings you know and they gave a
folded American flag to his family the
Democrats kneeled for eight minutes in
honor of them and explicitly said it was
in honor of them so these are things
that are celebrating and honoring the
man this is not just about speaking out
the end about the injustice of his death
is honoring and celebrating the men well
if we're gonna do that then I think it
becomes relevant to ask whether or not
he was actually an honorable man worthy
of celebration that's when you have to
look at you know not just his criminal
record but you look at the aggravated
armed robbery that he committed he
invaded a woman's home when her child
was present put a gun to her stomach and
robbed her okay
this this is a barbaric act of evil this
is extreme evil you think about what
what that does to a person is and this
is a woman who's traumatized for the
rest of her life as anyone would be
after a an experience like that and now
she I mean does anyone care about this
woman has anyone to have to her to see
how she feels but she has to walk by
murals celebrating her attacker and and
listen to all of this all of this
worship of him and that's just if we're
gonna do this if we're gonna say that
the evil perpetrated by great men like
Jefferson and Washington is reason
enough to tear down their statues and
what about their evil perpetrated by a
man who as far as we know as far as we
could tell never achieved anything great
in his life whatsoever
the only noteworthy thing about them is
is is the manner in which he died so
we're gonna we're gonna honor people now
based solely on how they died and not
they lived I think that that's perverse
and backwards so of course and and by
the way that standard would not be
applied to the to the people whose
statues are being torn down anyway even
that sort of reasoning of leaving it up
because it seems to me a little more
exploitative than all of this then all
were being told it seems to be more
exploitative than focusing on Washington
or focusing on George Floyd it seems to
me that the decision to tear down
statues and to build up murals and name
streets actually has absolutely nothing
to do with Washington and George Floyd
the men and it has everything to do with
this radical ideology that you touched
on at the very beginning we hear the
phrase black lives matter and black
lives matter has nothing to do with
black lives matter it is an avowed Lee
Marxist organization dedicated to the
destruction of the nuclear family I mean
really vicious awful unamerican stuff
all under this banner of this kind of
racial slogan and yet we've got elected
politicians on both sides of the aisle
proudly proclaiming the slogan yeah and
I would encourage anyone to actually go
to black lives matter what they have a
website you know the it's it's in modern
time so go to their website they they
they they uh they roll they show what
their mission statement is what they
believe they have a what we believe
section and what you're gonna find is
there's like one mention of police
brutality and that the rest of it is
radical far left stuff they mentioned
trans and gay issues over and over and
over again there's a very strange focus
on that because I thought this is
supposed to be black lives matter not
LGBT lives matter right but um and and
but and then there's a you know stuff
about dismantling the nuclear family and
undoing heteronormative
thinking and all these kinds of things
this is what these are the priorities of
white female Gender Studies students you
know this is not I think if we did a
poll of your average black American I
don't think many of them are gonna say
that their main things they worried
about when they wake up in the morning
or heteronormative thinking and
cisgender privilege yeah coming and a
queer affirming Network to foster blah
blah blah right exactly this this is not
it's got nothing to do with black lives
whatsoever they just put the its but
this
one of them one of the cleverest
branding decisions we've ever seen
anyone do where they put that in the
name of the organization right and now
we're being told that if you criticize
them you're criticizing the concept of
black lives mattering which which is
it's of course absurd that that's a
concept that almost nobody in America
disagrees with well we all agree that
black lives matter that is established
so let's go on to what this organization
actually stands for course you know it's
it seems to me it's it's so self
flattering to use the hashtag because
the the implication is well I think that
black lives matter but but there are and
everybody I know by the way thinks that
black lives matter but there are a great
many people out there in America those
deplorable irredeemable bad people who
think that black lives don't matter so
I've got a I've got to post this to show
those people and of course if you polled
the country statistically one hundred
percent of people would agree with that
sentiment but it's just the way be like
saying hey I'm I'm part of the do good
things organization and but when you
read the about us page it's a radical
narrow ideology but everybody wants to
signal to everyone else that they're a
good person that they're virtuous people
aren't reading the details but let me
tell you the devil is in the details
speaking of the devil by the way I got a
plug your book everyone needs to go at
and read NAT Walsh's book Church of
cowards which you know it ties into a
lot of the questions we're talking about
here on the spiritual erosion of the
country but it's also written in Matt's
inevitable style which is just sir Beck
and very funny
I encourage everybody to go read it and
Matt I've held you up from your flight
you've got to let go like run and catch
a flight right now yeah okay I go to
pick up my wife from a flight you got to
pick up your wife okay well that can't
wait then we'll have you through another
three segments that's great
she'll be fine she'll be fine thank you
sir appreciate it go watch the Matt
Walsh Oh Matt excellent to speak to you
and clarifying as always awesome
appreciate it thank you
all right thanks Bob this video is
sponsored by blink sale the
revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description